ya que vimos que las potencias de iu
reciclan en uno y menos uno y menos y me
gustaría utilizar ese hecho para hacer
algunos problemas que son más difíciles
pero que a la vez son más divertidos lo
que quiero que nos demos cuenta es que
en realidad ya podemos determinar y
elevado a cualquier potencia no importa
qué tan grande sea bueno entonces veamos
algunos ejemplos no sé imagínate que nos
piden que nos piden encontrar y elevado
a la potencia 100 si tienes un número
grandísimo verdad entonces parece ser un
problema difícil pero la idea clave es
que 100 es un múltiplo de 4 entonces
podemos reescribir y a las 100 como iu y
a la 4 x 25 100 es igual a 4 x 25 aquí
no he hecho nada raro pero luego usando
las leyes de los exponentes podemos
reescribir esta expresión como y a la
cuarta elevado elevado a la 25
4 por 25 es 100 y de este lado usamos
leyes de los exponentes si tenemos algo
dentro de un paréntesis elevado a otra
potencia se multiplican los exponentes
nada raro pero ahora la gran ventaja y
la razón por la cual puse aquí un y a la
cuarta es que sabemos que ya la cuarta
es igual a uno y eso simplifica
muchísimo las cosas porque entonces y a
la cuarta a la 25 es lo mismo que uno a
la 25 sí y a la cuarta es 1 y 1 a la 25
bueno uno a cualquier potencia es igual
a uno
entonces lo que utilizamos fue este
ciclo para determinar una potencia muy
grande
aprovechando que genera múltiplos de 4
pero de hecho este truco puede funcionar
aunque éste no sea un múltiplo de 4 por
ejemplo lo que podemos hacer es no sé
imagínate que nos piden determinar y
elevado a la potencia 501 vale entonces
el truco va a ser escribir este y a la
501 como y a la una potencia que es
múltiplo de 4 por y la otro número que
no necesariamente sea múltiplo de 4 a
qué me refiero con esto
este y a la 501 lo vamos a poner como a
la 500 porque 500 es múltiplo de 4 x y
va y entonces mismísima idea esto de
aquí es igual a éste y a la 500 es lo
mismo que a la cuarta elevado a las 125
si 4% 25 es 500 x y y otra vez mismísima
idea que aquí arriba y a la cuarta es
igual a 1 esto es esto es 1 a la 125 1 a
la cualquier cosa es 1 entonces
simplemente nos queda un uno por uno por
y que es igual a y sale déjame dejar
esto muy claro este término de acá es
este uno de aquí vale muy bien entonces
éste iv a la 501 parecía un problema muy
difícil así como para pasarse toda la
tarde haciendo una cuenta pero basta
utilizar este ciclo para simplificar las
cosas poner un exponente múltiplo de 4 y
que todo quede muy facilito vale de
hecho lo podemos poner un poco más en
general déjame poner por aquí lo que
concluimos de todo esto lo que
lo que concluimos es que y elevado a
cualquier múltiplo de 4 y elevado a
cualquier múltiplo de 4 es igual a 1
bueno vamos a ponerle ahorita que k es
mayor o igual que 0 y además que es un
entero vale es un entero no negativo
como lo hacemos para ver que se vale
para cualquier caso pues mismísima idea
tenemos que ir a la 4 cada usando leyes
de los exponentes es ya la cuarta
elevado a la k y luego ya la cuarta es 1
esto es 1 a la cara que es igual a 1
entonces se elevará a cualquier múltiplo
de 4 2 1 y si no es múltiplo de 4 lo
ajustamos vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos
más vale vamos a poner un ejemplo
todavía más loco déjame poner que
queremos calcular no sé algo así como
como y alas 7321 entonces cuál sería la
idea puedes encontrar el múltiplo de 4
más cercano a 7321 lo voy a poner y
ahorita te digo porque es lo voy a poner
como y al 7300 20
y yo digo que esto ya que es un múltiplo
de 4 porque ve este 1000 es múltiplo de
4 entonces 7000 lo es luego te estamos
sumando aquí 300 que también es múltiplo
de 4 y luego tenemos aquí un 20 y s 20
también es múltiplo de 4 entonces estoy
acá es ir a un múltiplo de 4 y
utilizando esta observación esto de aquí
es un 1 y esto de aquí es igual a y
entonces nos queda igual y vamos a hacer
uno más ya como que está muy rápido
hacer estos problemas verdad entonces
vamos a hacer otros cuantos más déjame
poner no sé digamos y a la 99 si quieres
puedes pasar el vídeo para intentar los
pero lo voy a hacer este día a la 99
misma idea un múltiplo de 4 cercano al
99 pues 100 es múltiplo de 4 4 696
entonces 96 es múltiplo de 4 y luego hay
que multiplicar por y al cubo y a la 96
por y al cubo es a la 99 leyes de los
exponentes de todo normalito pero ahora
aquí tenemos y a la 96 que es un 1
simplemente nos queda
y bueno aquí nos podemos acordar que
esto es igual a menos y menos y bueno si
no nos acordamos podemos calcularlo de
la siguiente manera déjalo borró si no
nos acordamos que esto es igual a menos
si lo ponemos como y al cuadrado por iu
y lo que sí hay que acordarnos es que y
al cuadrado es menos 1 entonces esto es
menos uno por y que es menos y muy bien
ya nada más déjame hacer uno último para
que quede súper clara esta idea voy a
poner digamos y a la 38 y a la 38 y
vamos a ver que nos queda y a la 38 es
lo mismo que a la 36 x al cuadrado 36 es
múltiplo de 4 este es un 1 nos queda y
al cuadrado y ya sabemos que al cuadrado
es igual a menos 1 muy bien